ante un riesgo nuclear creciente la
búsqueda de un compromiso en un vehículo
blindado del ejército ruso el jefe del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica Rafael grossi llegó a saporilla
para inspeccionar la central nuclear
grossi lleva meses llevando a cabo
consultas para la protección de la zona
que sufre ataques regulares haciendo
tener un accidente nuclear hasta ahora
las discusiones habían centrado en un
perímetro de seguridad alrededor de la
central pero el jefe del oesía declaró
que el compromiso debía ser la central
ahora el concepto está evolucionando se
está centrando más en la protección en
las cosas que deben evitarse por ejemplo
para proteger la planta que en los
aspectos territoriales que plantean
ciertos problemas pero es un trabajo en
curso diría yo estamos trabajando con
ambos gobiernos
el lunes el presidente ucraniano
y Rafael grossi se reunieron en una
central hidroeléctrica en hiper el
dirigente ucraniano había advertido que
cualquier iniciativa para restablecer la
seguridad nuclear sería un fracaso sin
La retirada de los rusos pero grossy
aseguró que seguía buscando una solución
para evitar una catástrofe
no me doy por vencido creo que al
contrario tenemos que multiplicar
nuestros esfuerzos Tenemos que continuar
a principios de este mes la central
había sufrido un ataque
advirtió entonces de que se está jugando
con fuego Mientras que el jefe de la
diplomacia de la Unión Europea josep
borrell acusó a Rusia de poner en
peligro la seguridad de todo el
continente europeo Rusia por su parte
reivindica la región de saporicha y
acusa a Ucrania de aumentar sus ataques
por su parte el viceministro ruso de
exteriores sergey afirmó que Moscú
dejara de compartir su información
nuclear con Estados Unidos